[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié avoisiner sorti tout
de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi 2
février la deuxième édition de beule sky
festival de la bande dessinée de saint
quentin en yvelines où débute le 7
février des ateliers des animations et
même des projections sont organisées
dans toutes les médiathèques du réseau
jusqu'au 4 mars
julien allès responsables du festival
blues nous aidera à former tant sur la
programmation
les doudous m'ont envoyé la salle
d'exposition de guyancourt peluches et
nina lous petits monstres le doudou
c'est le compagnon inoubliable celui à
qui on confier chacun de nos secrets
avec lequel ont joué le plus souvent
retour en enfance avec cette exposition
harry potter à l'école des sorciers fête
ses 20 ans et pour l'occasion un
week-end de magie vous attend dans les
yvelines amis moldus sont invités chez
les furets du noir ou à l'armoire guiche
pour célébrer cet anniversaire mélanie
nous donnera le programme
elisabeth by a débuté la photographie
par curiosité l'artiste a découvert le
8e art grâce à son père est au travail
argentique ses spécialités la prise de
vue naturel le tirage sur différents
supports comme le textile
elle expose jusqu'au 17 février au
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux et ils seront en première
partie du groupe diva phone ce samedi 3
février lady bird et son pop rock
électro rythmera la scène de la batterie
de guyancourt formé en 2012 le groupe a
sorti un premier ep et se prépare à nous
présenter son album where did you go la
formation mêle guitare moderne sonorités
hip hop et électro on écoute l'extrait
better pour se donner une idée
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
google sky festival de la bande dessinée
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines revient
pour une deuxième édition jusqu'au 4
mars les médiathèques du réseau vous
propose un voyage au japon pour aller à
la découverte du manga mais il y aura
aussi du cinéma des ateliers et des
rencontres avec des professionnels
julien menait ce responsable adjoint de
la médiathèque jacques brel de magny les
hameaux et responsables du festival est
avec nous bonjour je alors je l'évoqué
rapidement et pour cette deuxième
édition c'est vraiment le pays du soleil
levant qui est mis à l'honneur
absolument alors pour quelle raison
parce que le manga c'est un média c'est
un support qui parle à beaucoup de monde
peut-être pas assez parce que c'est
beaucoup plus multi générationnel qu'on
croit et c'est toujours intéressant de
mettre en avant comme ça ces supports
qui sont un peu méconnu et qui
mériteraient de l'être plus alors qu'est
ce qui caractérise le style manga dont
on connaît un peu des personnages on
voit à peu près mais qu'est ce qui
caractérise vraiment ce style assez
particulier
on voit à peu près les personnages qui
sont dans tous les sens avec des gros
yeux effectivement d'un point de vue
technique c'est un support qui est plus
petit que la bd qu'on connaît qui se lit
inhabituellement à l'envers qui est
souvent en noir et blanc
après au niveau des histoires ça va dans
tous les sens au même titre que la bd au
même titre que la comics aux états unis
ça peut être ce qu'on appelle shôjo pour
les jeunes filles shônen pour les jeunes
vers son hussein n pour les adultes et
tous les âges il ya vraiment de tout
dans le monde et il ya des ateliers 1
qui seront animées juste ans par un
mangaka donc un professionnel un
dessinateur de manga yoshimi qu'attache
ira alors qu'est-ce qui la prendra
justement aux jeunes comment ça va se
passer un petit peu ces ateliers
et bien c'est des ateliers à la base
tout ce qu'il ya de plus classique
celles intervenant ici qui est un peu
particulier
les enfants vont travailler sur des
thématiques que vous pourrez découvrir
sur le programme qui vont être répartis
un petit peu surtout saint quentin en
yvelines et ça va être travaillée par
exemple est ici le scénario ici le
dessin fantastique ici la créativité
brut etc etc et au delà du de la bande
dessinée japonaise c'est vraiment la
culture japonaise qui est qui est mise à
l'honneur que vous inviter à découvrir
notamment dans certaines madiata qu'il y
aura il sera aussi question de contes et
de kamishibaï alors qu'est ce que c'est
que les kamishibaï par exemple les
kamishibaï ont pour simplifier on
pourrait dire que c'est des petites des
petits théâtres portable qui permet de
raconter des décomptes de manière plus
interactif avec des supports carton et
qui permet oui aux collègues et aux et
aux enfants qui participent à sa d'être
plus dans dans le texte dans l'histoire
donc l'idée c'est vraiment nous plonger
un petit peu au coeur des légendes de
l'élection qui ont fait qu'ils ont fait
payer justement absolument deux
expositions sont aussi mises en place
alors bubble stick et golden qui lui est
mal viraux acadomia lorsqu'on peut nous
en dire un peu plus
alors pour ce qui est des blue bulls tic
en fait c'est un travail qu'a fait la
médiathèque du canal avec le
conservatoire de montigny et céder des
stickers faits par les enfants qui vont
être collé un petit peu dans toute la
médiathèque
et pour ce qui est de
l'autre l'exposition qui osent puisque
c'est la maison d'édition ki moon qui
nous la fournit ça va tourner sur de
manga donc justement à manga pour les
jeunes plutôt my rock à denia qu'un
manga qui a été un des cartons l'année
dernière est un manga seinen sur les
chercheurs sur les chercheurs d'or qui
s'appelle golding et mickael manga très
sympa aussi tout public très très bien
documenté je précise que ces deux ces
deux expos sa campagne dans l'évolution
des mangas qui savent pas ce qu on
appelle les mangas qui ça c'est des
endroits qui sont dédiés aux mangas et
donc qui permettent aux tous les âges
devenir de s'asseoir de lire de
bouquiner dans un endroit vraiment cosy
sympa donc on peut on n'est pas
forcément obligé de participer aux
ateliers on peut aussi juste venir dire
tranquille parce que l'une profiter il
n'y a pas que les médiathèques aussi qui
participent à ce festival différentes
projections sont aussi proposés les
cinémas participe aussi à lors des
projections il n'a dans certaines des
médiathèques mais il ya aussi surtout
les cinémas locaux du territoire je
passe toutes les salles mais absolument
toutes les salles locales du territoire
participent et propose une programmation
qui est dédié au japon et au manga
qu'est-ce qu'on a continué un petit peu
par exemple la deux têtes y en a
beaucoup
ouais on est surtout sur du tout âge on
a deux soirées sur le territoire de
soirée qu'ils vont vraiment être pour
les adultes et pour les grands enfants
on va dire ça comme ça
par contre sur les matinées on a
beaucoup beaucoup de films pour les
petits j'ai cru voir passer le voyage de
chihiro
ouais je crois l'avoir vu fido ghibli à
ce genre de choses et donc vous l'avez
évoqué il ya aussi pour les adultes en
fait l'idée c'est vraiment soit
intergénérationnel sur la whey l'idée
c'est aussi de montrer que le manga
c'est pas forcément l'image qu'on a tous
des années 80 avec les mangas quitté
parcours en force d'un club dorothée
c'est pour les gamins et c'est violent
et tout ça c'est pas ça le manga ça
c'est l'image qu'on a eu à une certaine
époque le manga c'est infiniment plus
riche que ça et ça mérite parfois mais
qu'on y jette un petit coup d'oeil
comment est venue justement l'idée de
créer ce festival globule sky à la base
bum existait déjà sur le titre peut-être
de manière moins appuyée mais c'était le
travail collectif de tous les référents
bd du réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines qui s'éclate et
qu'ils voulaient sur le temps sur le
temps de janvier initialement mettre en
avant la bd et puis ça s'est transformé
on a trouvé un nom c'est devenu babel
scary aujourd'hui c'est devenu ce que
c'est en tout cas à découvrir dès le 7
février
merci beaucoup je les emmenais ce
responsable de ce festival bébel sky
nous avoir parlé des différents
événements qui nous attendent jusqu'au 4
mars
on le rappelle ça commence le 7 février
et toute la programmation du festival
est à retrouver sur le site internet des
médiathèques du réseau merci beaucoup je
n'ai rien retrouvé l'enfant qui est en
soi grâce à une exposition les doudous
sous toutes leurs coutures sont à
l'honneur à guyancourt
les artistes ont réalisé leurs créations
avec la complicité des habitants
un travail collectif découvrir là aussi
jusqu'au 4 mars
découverte sur ces images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un doudou c'est plus qu'un copain de jeu
c'est un véritable compagnon de vie qui
soit peluche animal petits monstres
il sèche les larmes plus petit et
rassure les enfants un ami doudou
ça évoque je pense pour n'importe quelle
personne là bas son enfance évidemment
après en tant que parent bas
on a une deuxième vie avec nos propres
enfants sur le doubs
moi j'ai pas eu de doudou nounours
j'avais juste un tee shirt que je trais
fuyait voilà et c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu mettre en avant le textile parce
que je pense qu'un doudou c'est pas
forcément une peluche
ça peut être tout toutes sortes de
petits bouts de couverture de tee-shirts
[Musique]
une exposition réalisée par une dizaine
d'artistes avec la participation des
habitants de guyancourt
pour accompagner le visiteur bagatelle
est colossal de doudou imaginé par les
enfants des écoles de la ville nano nos
mascottes bagatelle est colossal voilà
qui ont été faits par marie-claire duyse
une bénévole car produit vraiment à
l'identique les dessins des enfants
on avait plus de 500 dessins donc ça a
été très très difficile de choisir
l'expérience visuelle tactile et
sensorielle pour pour jouer au mieux
dans ce monde de douceur les visiteurs
sont invités à déambuler sans chaussures
un retour en enfance à l'insouciance et
on change d'ambiance j'imagine que vous
avez bien sûr reconnu la musique c'est
celle de harry potter car un week-end de
magie vous attend le jeune sorcier est à
la fête pour un anniversaire avec nous
une fan bonjour mélanie voir camille la
wii c'est un anniversaire pour un bel
âge puisque le premier libre à tout
juste 20 ans était harry potter à
l'école des sorciers
alors nous ça ne nous rajeunit pas les
téléspectateurs retrouveront peut-être
un peu trop jeune pour que cette
séquence mais vous qu emilie est ce que
vous l'avez lu et surtout qu'est ce que
vous en retour nous retourner alors je
mange léger lui mais il ya effectivement
assez longtemps comme vous le dites ça
ça rajeunit pas mais je suis plutôt du
film je pense que les jeunes aux
spectateurs aussi connaissent peut-être
sont plutôt les films et cet
anniversaire les
les libraires ne manque pas de le
célébrer notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines
oui alors les deux cultures a qui sont à
plaisir et rambouillet eux l'ont fêté
hier jeudi 1er février et ce samedi
c'est au tour des furet du nord à
skywest alors toute une après midi
magique avec différentes activités et on
fait le point avec servane guez qu'il
responsable de l'enseignent a commencé
par une cérémonie de répartition avec le
choixpeau pour savoir dans quelle maison
on va être envoyée donc il ya des êtres
des ateliers qui sont pour les plus
grands mais aussi pour les plus jeunes
des ateliers créatifs des quiz des jeux
voilà tout ça tournait autour du monde
des sorciers d'harry potter et on
suppose qu'il ya des inscriptions quand
même oui bien sûr pour éviter peut-être
un peu de co et alors il faut se
rapprocher bien sûr de la boutique via
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran mais aussi les réseaux sociaux
médias pas qu' il n'y a pas que les
furet du nord puisque à versailles aussi
on célèbre le célèbre sorcier
cette fois c'est al ahmar l'armoire geek
est une boutique spécialisée spécialisés
ont fait harry potter jusqu'au 4 février
la au programme des jeux de piste
carrément dans la ville pour retrouver
les animaux cachés
il y aussi des photos shootées pourquoi
pas faire un tournoi des champions ça va
rappeler un certain livre le quatrième
alors là les informations ne sont pas à
trouver dans la gazette du sorcier mais
bien sur le site internet et bien sûr
n'oubliez pas votre plus belle baguette
et votre chapeau de sorcière sinon vous
passerez pour un moldu merci beaucoup
mais la livre de ken maison en fait à
dur il pourrait dire qu'il faudra pour
cela prochaine
les plus courageux merci en tout cas de
nous avoir parlé de ce week-end spécial
harry potter on passe maintenant notre
agenda avec deux rendez vous sportif a
noté un grand gala de muay thaï est
organisée ce samedi à sartrouville
enjeux des ceintures mondiales et
européennes dans les catégories
masculines et féminines
au total des dizaines de combat seront
programmées pendant toute la soirée au
gymnase louis paulhan après avoir
accueilli un match de championnat en
2016 entre eux ici paris et brest le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
va accueillir ce samedi 3 février une
rencontre de coupe d'europe
ici paris va défier l'équipe norvégienne
de viper ce kristianstad au 4ème tour de
la compétition
plus de 4000 spectateurs sont attendus
pour cette rencontre
c'est une loisirs est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivis et n'oubliez
pas que ce vendredi 2 février c'est la
chandeleur donc profitez-en pour vous
régaler avec des crêpes en famille ou
entre amis on se retrouve nous vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et d'ici
là je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
vous